ladies I have a pro tip for when you're
in the gym and men are making you
uncomfortable I was doing my squats you
know popping that booty she belongs to
the street
and directly behind me happens to be a
man on the treadmill I heard him say I
just want to say one this is not a
personality this is a this is not that's
not a what is this no person talks like
this so this is someone with no
personality who's who's trying to do an
imitation of what she believes a
personality is and she but she she has
constructed her personality from memes
that she's seen so this is someone who's
taken a bunch of memes and cobbled them
together into her imitation of what a
personality is and this is what you end
up with